chris unveiled on his podcast yesterday
his top corners and his top safeties
entering the draft
uh
and i don't see jc horn
on your list of top corners
so you're one of the experts he's
already calling out chris
right i i see he's keeping a list like
ryan in the office when uh you know he
had his downfall and he's got his pen
and paper and he marks you know he's
marks off the name of everyone who who
has wronged him why is he not on your
list keeping a list checking it twice
trying to find out who's naughty and
nice that's what he's doing right i mean
first off
i like the player i do he's got
incredible size and strength combination
that's where he is but to me again you
know you heard my little explanation a
little bit on my podcast and what i look
for in corners
there's not enough top end speed
for me to make him a first round corner
he's a specialized corner he'd have to
play in maybe a seattle scheme or he's
going to have to match up against only
the big receivers or the tight ends to
me
it's just not enough pure like straight
ahead explosion
not good enough at coming out of cuts
and and accelerating to break on the
ball you know it's just that that's my
concern there and that's what i'm about
with corner you know that's again where
i go to corner you talk about the top
corners and football you know
in the history of the sport too
they're running 4-3 they're running low
four fours and they play faster than the
low 4-4
when you're running 4-5
or high four fours or high four fives
i'm just you're gonna how you're gonna
cover tyree kill you're gonna you're
gonna cover odell beckham jrs of the
world and stefan diggs and those guys no
you're not
and that's where i always come back to
and to me yes that's the number one
thing i look for
it is such a critical position and it's
so difficult because
the receiver always knows where he's
going right the corner doesn't and
there's only so much you can glean from
film study the best receivers are not
going to have any tells any indication
any hint as to where they're going to go
they're trying to sell you that they're
going out when they go in right they're
trying to sell you they're going short
when they go long and they are
incredible physical specimens and you
are too but they have the advantage
because they know where they're going
and it is a natural disadvantage and i
think it makes it even more important to
have this to gravitate toward fast guys
who can recover
when
the receiver zigs when the corner
thought maybe he would zag gilmore jair
alexander marshawn lattimore
you know marlon humphrey william jackson
who just signed the big contract byron
jones they're all high four three guys
they're all high four three guys how do
you expect a guy to cover a guy who runs
four three or four four flat when the
guy covering him like you said doesn't
know where he's going and he runs four
or five you know that's the big thing
and that you know like we have a
question from at kmart 2180 i want to
read this he goes where do you rank or
where do you rank jc horn if he's not in
your top six i'm also confused with your
emphasis on speed richard sherman always
ranks as the top cornerback in every
category and he's not a blazing speed
man yeah he's a system fit he is a
system fit there's a reason you've only
seen him in the seattle scheme because
he doesn't he's not a great man-to-man
corner if he had to play in baltimore or
new england
uh or or or kansas city as much as they
play man-to-man it ain't gonna work
buddy that's what i'm telling you so
that to me you know again i really like
richard sherman he's going to the hall
of fame but for me too he's
also a hair overrated that way because
it is only a system bit i bring guys to
go they fit in any system man-to-man
every play they could play the seattle
scheme if they had to but really seattle
schemes they don't look to they don't
look to get usually top end corners a
whole lot because they go we don't play
man so i don't want to get a top end
corner you know so that that's my answer
to that i like jc horn he's right past
those top six he's seven or eight for me
but yes he's not a first round talent
just because of that you know lack of
what we talked about there
of the corners and we've got the list
we'll put it back up which of the ones
that you've evaluated reminds you of one
of the best corners currently in
football rams cornerback jaylen ramsey
oh
it's the guy right at the top there mike
this this kid's the real deal holyfield
you know caleb farley from virginia tech
he didn't play last year
but hey we saw jeffrey akuda go at
number three last year and i go well
then this guy could go number one i
don't know i mean this guy's a he's a
freak i have not seen a corner this big
be able to move like this since jalen
ramsey in a lot of ways and i'm going to
say this because you know i got a man
crush on jaylen ramsey he moves better
than jalen ramsey did coming out of
florida state i i was blown away i knew
there was hype around this guy but when
i turned it on i just went whoa he's big
he can fly he could stick his foot in
the ground and drive on the ball like a
top tier wide receiver he's got really
good ball skills and he's kind of just
doing it raw like he hasn't been taught
a whole lot yet and mike i'm big on
again going back to the aspect of like
hey you got that guy when i see colleges
start doing that i go oh they they know
he's kind of special he can do that and
he's one of those guys
question
and you take caleb farley over zach
wilson uh
no i would not and a little bit because
of the reason first off you know i love
zach wilson i think he's superstar but
the jets are gonna run that seattle
scheme they're not a huge man-to-man
football team that's not what they do so
i don't think they're gonna value a
number two pick for the corner position
like that
let's talk about safety for a minute or
two we have the board of your rankings
there
my question is which one reminds you of
jamal adams and my guess is whoever it
is he's probably the top guy on your
list that's right yeah yeah i mean
you're right i think it would be cisco
is like that proto andre cisco from
syracuse is that prototypical guy now
here there's a little you know hitch in
the giddy up here because he tore his
acl you know last year but man when you
talk when i'm when we're saying like
jamal adams and you asked me that
question what i'm thinking of a guy who
got great speed a ball hawk and will
absolutely knock your head off if you
come into the hole or there's a pulling
guard or doing something like that cisco
is like that cisco is like rocked up
like a jamal adams and you got to be if
you're going to be that type of safety
and i would say with jamal adams maybe
he's not quite as a good as or not as
big as jamal but he's faster than jamal
cisco is one of those guys when you turn
on the film you go i think he might run
438 439 something like that he's that
kind of speed he was he was really
special uh i'm a big fan of his i think
the the only thing i question is just
you know where teams feel about his
injury and stuff like that
jc horn is the son of saints receiver
joe horn patrick certain the second
alabama corner the son of patrick
certain who was a great corner in his
day what do you what do you see in him
well i i mean
he's he is a technician and we talked a
little bit yesterday right because of
his pro day and stuff i mean the size
you know unbelievable hips
he's great at again being able to put
his foot in the ground and not take a
lot of wasted steps and drive on the
ball
my only concern with certain is what you
heard yesterday and this is why i have
him number three behind tyson campbell
and caleb farley is just the pure speed
element you know i know he he ran 442 at
his pro day i would again like to remind
everybody
that 442 was 4-5-2 with the nfl combine
all the really smart defensive coaches
and secondary coaches are going to add a
tent to that time
to go nah that's not real 442 of your
pro day is not not the same thing so
he's a top 15 pick i'm i really like the
guy but as far as like caleb farley or
the guy tyson campbell in front of him
who has a lot of the same measurables he
does you know they just have better pure
speed and acceleration and explosion and
that's why i rank them ahead of him
um
overall this class you know we've talked
about how many great receivers there are
there's going to be a bunch of
quarterbacks in round one this class of
corners and safeties how does it compare
to others yeah that's a good question i
think the the the top end corners are
really damn good like i like these three
caleb farley tyson campbell and certain
better than i'd like the top three last
year and i was a big fan of you know ej
henderson and aj tyrell i love them i
mean i ranked them in front of a cuda
i think these three are pretty special i
will say at the corner position i think
there's a little bit of a drop off after
these six uh safety this year mike that
was the one where i just felt like it
was a never-ending list that was one
where i kept looking at and going man
here's another good one well he's number
nine on my list here but
he's gonna be he could be a starter next
year and be good for a football team so
the safety is the position where i think
there's a lot of guys that have
versatility aspects and it's just going
to be about how a team views the safety
and how they want to use them all
together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports